una de las cosas que probablemente
causan más problemas en química y en
química orgánica en particular es
justamente la notación y la nomenclatura
de todas las moléculas con las que
trabajamos y lo que quiero hacer en este
vídeo y en los próximos vídeos es
asegurarme de que tengamos un buen
entendimiento en la anotación y en la
nomenclatura o cómo le ponemos nombre a
todo a todas las moléculas con las que
vamos a trabajar y lo demás espero que
no sea muy difícil así que para empezar
y esto realmente solo un repaso de
química orgánica digamos que tengo una
cadena de carbonos ok bueno por supuesto
no sé quizás el nombre de cadena no es
la adecuada pero en química orgánica
trabajamos con cadenas de carbonos aquí
vamos a pintar solo sólo un carbono
verdad una cadena de un carbono así que
realmente sería ridículo llamarle cadena
pero si tenemos un carbono por aquí en
realidad este carbono tiene 4 electrones
de valencia verdad tiene 4 electrones de
valencia verdad y sabemos que quiere
alcanzar los 8 ese es el número
porque aprendimos en química regular
verdad para todas las moléculas hla
digamos la estructura estable de
valencia podríamos llamarle de alguna
forma es justo el 8 el que queremos
alcanzar verdad y un buen amigo un buen
compañero que puede tener este carbono
podría ser justamente el hidrógeno
verdad así que si ponemos un hidrógeno
aquí el hidrógeno
este hidrógeno comparte un electrón
podemos hacer esto mismo en cada uno de
estos lados que compartan un electrón en
cada lado verdad entonces de esta forma
el carbono ya alcanzó el número 8 ya
tiene 8 electrones alrededor de él
mientras que el el hidrógeno no no
alcanza el 8 verdad pero dijimos que
justamente el número mágico del 8 aplica
para todos excepto para el hidrógeno y
el helio porque ellos están muy felices
simplemente tratando de llenar su
orbital 1 es verdad así que el número
mágico para el helio y para el hidrógeno
así que ahora también todos los
hidrógenos díaz deben sentirse muy
contentos porque tienen dos electrones
para cada uno verdad y alcanzaron ese
número y este carbono ya tiene 8 ahora
hay muchas formas de escribir esto
podríamos dejar esta molécula con sus
electrones aquí bien explícitos o
simplemente podríamos poner enlaces
verdad en vez de poner estos electrones
vamos a poner enlaces que es que es lo
que me refiero con enlaces ponemos
nuestro carbono y en vez de este par de
electrones ponemos justamente líneas que
son enlaces verdad entonces a cada
enlace le corresponde un hidrógeno
tenemos un hidrógeno en cada enlace y
pues podemos imaginar que cada enlace en
realidad equivale a dos electrones
verdad y que justamente como es un
enlace covalente lo están compartiendo
ahora vamos a hacer otro ejemplo algo
que sí parezca cadena de verdad aunque
entonces vamos a poner una cadena de 3
carbonos digamos tenemos un carbono y
tiene sus 4 electrones déjenme ponerlos
un poco separados tiene 4 electrones de
valencia verdad digamos que este carbono
está unido a otro carbono déjenme
todavía hacer más separado esto
aunque digamos que tiene esto así esto
así vamos a hacerlo más separado aquí
y aquí ok entonces digamos que este
carbono está unido a otro carbono y este
carbono pues justamente va a compartir
un electrón verdad y este tiene
nuevamente 4 electrones de valencia
déjeme hacerlo más separado para que sea
un poco más claro por supuesto esto es
un poco de lata verdad es es complicado
y si este carbono está unido a otro
carbono este comparte un electrón con
este carbono y tiene 4 verdad nuevamente
tiene 4
tiene 4 electrones de valencia ahora
bien si no especificamos que más pues
estos van a estar unidos a hidrógenos
verdad entonces estos hidrógenos
comparten el electrón y así estos
carbonos pues ya están contentos porque
cada uno tiene 8 electrones alrededor y
los hidrógenos también verdad los
hidrógenos también porque tienen 2
electrones que es justo el número mágico
para el hidrógeno ahora bien esto podría
parecer una verdadera lata verdad es muy
complicado eso aunque es una molécula
bien formada pero desgaste estar
dibujando dibujando los electrones de
valencia así que podemos ver lo más
fácil con líneas verdad es más fácil si
ponemos estos tres carbonos conectados
con enlaces es verdad que significa que
comparten dos electrones y a cada uno de
ellos le ponemos los hidrógenos
correspondientes por ejemplo el primero
tenía 3 el segundo tenía 2 de esta forma
y el tercero tenía 3
tenía tres hidrógenos verdad entonces
esta es una forma mucho más sencilla es
más limpio y es más rápido y tiene
exactamente la misma idea ahora bien
esta molécula solo para irnos adentrando
en la nomenclatura se le llama propano
verdad mientras que a la molécula
anterior se le conoce como metano
entonces ya puedes irte dando una idea
de cuáles son las reglas que vamos a
tener para las cadenas que tienen
enlaces sencillos verdad entonces esto
lo veremos en otros vídeos cómo asignar
nombres con mucha más calma ahorita
quiero que veamos otra forma mucho más
compacta y más sencilla de representar
esta molécula por ejemplo aquí tenemos
una un grupo que es ch3 verdad tenemos
un ch3 mientras que en medio tenemos un
h 2 verdad tenemos un carbono y dos
hidrógenos entonces podemos unir este sh
3 con este ch2 verdad y finalmente
tenemos este que es otro ch 3 entonces
esta forma es todavía más sencilla y más
compacta y tiene exactamente la misma
información
ahora bien todavía tenemos una forma más
simple verdad vamos a ponerlo de la
siguiente forma vamos a poner esto es lo
que se conoce como una estructura de
enlace línea y vamos a poner este
diagrama así y entonces tú te estarás
preguntando oye qué bueno que se ve más
simple pero cómo es que ese diagrama tan
ridículo representa a toda la molécula y
en realidad es que en química y en
química orgánica en particular
los químicos se han arreglado para poder
representar esto a estas moléculas de
forma más sencilla porque muchas veces
tenemos moléculas tan grandes y tan
complicadas que es difícil o es muy
engorroso estar pintando todos los
hidrógenos y todos los enlaces verdad
entonces lo que nos está diciendo este
diagrama es en cada extremo de estas
líneas tenemos un carbono en cada
extremo tenemos un carbono y nosotros
sabemos que el carbono tiene cuatro
enlaces entonces si no tenemos nada más
explícito esto me está diciendo que cada
uno de estos carbonos implícitamente me
está diciendo que está unido a los
hidrógenos que le quepan verdad en este
caso ya está unido a un carbono aquí hay
un enlace así que le restan 3 entonces
implícitamente me dice que este carbono
del del extremo izquierdo está unido a 3
hidrógenos este de aquí estaría unido a
dos hidrógenos y este de aquí estaría
unido a otros 3 hidrógenos muy bien
entonces esta es la la forma de entender
este diagrama que es mucho más sencillo
pero que contiene la información
anterior verdad y en ocasiones podemos
combinar estas dos estas estas dos
digamos dos formas de trabajarlo por
ejemplo podríamos poner esto 11 h 3
este tipo de enlaces unido a 11h 3
entonces tenemos ch3 que es esta
información
y aquí implícitamente me está diciendo
que hay dos hidrógenos verdad entonces
estamos combinando esto y todas son
formas válidas de escribir esta molécula
o de representar la digamos gráficamente
todas estas son formas válidas de
dibujar la estructura molecular de estas
cadenas de carbono o de o de compuestos
orgánicos